affluence record pour le salon de
l'agriculture qui vient de fermer ses
portes que six cent mille visiteurs en
une semaine
d'élan dans ce journal halte à la
douleur bernard kouchner lance un plan
sur trois ans pour améliorer remédier
les insuffisances dans le traitement de
la douleur de nouvelles mesures et une
campagne d'information
j'en internationale des femmes avec la
souffrance des femmes afghanes depuis le
régime des talibans elles ne peuvent ni
travailler ni étudié l'enquète dans ce
journal à kaboul et dans les camps de
réfugiés
pour cette journée des familles à
quelques jours des régionales invités de
cette édition dominique voynet début de
la saison de formule 1 avec la victoire
des mclaren au grand prix d'australie
c'est le finlandais mika qui viennent
qui a remporté la première épreuve
bredouillait à paris avec la célèbre
comédie musicale fame sur la scène des
folies bergères une troupe entièrement
américaine
madame monsieur bonsoir c'est sous le
signe de la réconciliation que vient de
s'achever le salon de l'agriculture un
succès incontestable record de
fréquentation jamais atteint plus de 600
mille visiteurs en une semaine et
surtout de nouveaux liens de confiance
entre le monde agricole et les
consommateurs reportage j'arrive perrin
jean marc sur st la barre des 600 mille
visiteurs dépassés cela fait neuf ans
que l'on avait connu pareille affluence
l'agriculture de salon attire les foules
les professionnels ont tout fait pour se
réconcilier avec les consommateurs
finis les vieux slogans sur
l'agriculture productiviste et
exportatrices
cette année les mots d'ordre sont
qualité terroir authenticité le salon a
gommé volontairement toute référence à
l'agriculture industrielle et
pèse pourtant plus de 90% du secteur et
à l'avant et l'après crise de la vache
folle aujourd'hui tout le monde a pris
conscience qu'il fallait plus
communiquant avec les consommateurs les
consommateurs d'ailleurs sont plus
exigeants un aussi avec nous et vous ce
dialogue que cette alliance entre
producteurs et consommateurs
je crois que naît une sorte une nouvelle
façon de travailler entre nous tous ce
n'est donc pas un hasard si la bio
débarque en force au salon bien appuyé
il faut le dire par deux chaînes de la
grande distribution oublier les stands
un peu bancal d'antan tenus par des
pionniers convaincu grandes surfaces
plus air du temps égal nouveau public
ça correspond pour nous à la
capitalisation de d'années et deux
décennies travail enfin on est reconnu
le danger maintenant c'est ce qu'on va
être capables de créer de gérer la
croissance de travailler en bonne
intelligence avec nos partenaires de la
distribution de la transformation
côté innovation marguerite le premier
veau ou issus d'un clonage tout le salon
en a parlé mais margueritte n'était pas
vraiment là
sauf sur scène en vidéo pour les
chercheurs c'est une avancée majeure
elle profitera d'abord à la médecine et
curieusement pas vraiment à
l'agriculture la classe politique est
extrêmement réservé mesuré après
l'annoncé de la convocation de roland
dumas chez les juges le 18 mars prochain
si les avocats du président du conseil
constitutionnel ne parle pas
explicitement de mise en examen
en revanche il souligne l'incompétence
de la justice ordinaire et demandent la
saisine de la cour de justice de la
république olivier caroff la cour de
justice de la république va t'elle
hérité de l'instruction en cours sur les
commissions versées à une proche de
roland dumas
c'est ce que souhaitent les avocats du
président du conseil constitutionnel
dans une lettre aux plus hautes
autorités judiciaires ils demandent la
saisine de cette cour composée de trois
magistrats six députés et six sénateurs
c'est la seule instance habilitée à
juger un ministre pour les crimes et
délits commis dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions
les juges laurence vichnievsky et eva
joly
actuellement en charge du dossier serait
alors automatiquement des saisi la cour
de justice de la république elle a une
commission d'instruction
la commission d'instruction pourra agir
comme le font les juges aujourd'hui par
conséquent en aucune façon il ne peut
s'agir pour monsieur roland dumas d'une
dérobade quelconque pour les défenseurs
de roland dumas l'effet que selon leur
expression les deux juges veulent lui
reprochés sont nécessairement liée à son
activité de ministre des affaires
étrangères à l'époque où se négociait la
vente des frégates à taïwan sous les
gouvernements de michel rocard puis
d'edith cresson un débat juridique que
la plupart des politiques se refuse à
alimenter
si c'est les tribunaux ordinaires mais à
écouter ce seront les tribunes ordina
qui statueront si c'est la cour de
justice
eh bien ce sera la cour de justice mais
là dessus je suis un simple citoyen qui
respecte la justice et qui veut que la
justice aille vite aille en toute
indépendance et travaille bien dans la
sérénité concept devrait plus dense
également à droite même si certains
s'interrogent sur les conséquences d'une
éventuelle mise en examen
il n'a pas d'obligation juridique mais
moi je n'imagine pas qu'un président du
conseil constitutionnel mise en cause
dans des affaires aussi graves puissent
rester en fonction l'instruction elle
continue avant roland dumas c'est loïc
le floch prigent l'ancien pdg d'elf qui
devrait se rendre dès demain au palais
de justice pour être entendu sur cette
affaire au delà de la question de la
procédure judiciaire procédure normale
ou cour de justice et en raison de la
haute fonction exercée par roland dumas
cette affaire soulève des questions
graves albert du roy cette affaire est
doublement importante d'abord sur le
plan judiciaire
une fois de plus l'instruction
théoriquement secrète se déroule sur la
place publique
roland dumas est présumé mis en examen
dix jours avant sa convocation chez le
juge d'instruction alors pourquoi ce
fonctionnement normal de la justice mais
ya deux hypothèses ou bien les
magistrats traite les règles par dessus
la jambe ce qui mettrait en cause leur
conscience professionnelle ou bien ils
craignent qu'une instruction sur un
sujet et sur un personnage sensible ne
puisse pas être mené à son terme si elle
n'est pas publique et cela mettrait en
cause l'indépendance de la justice
deuxième point d'importance et sur le
plan politique et institutionnel
le conseil constitutionnel et le gardien
du texte fondamental de la république
qui est la constitution
il a réussi jusqu'à présent à préserver
sa réputation et a assuré son autorité
ce qui touche à l'un de ses membres et a
fortiori à son président portent
évidemment atteinte à la crédibilité de
l'institution s'il arbitre suprême est
suspect et bien c'est une situation qui
évidemment est dangereuse alors au delà
de ce qu'on appelle la sphère du mas est
ce qu'il est innocent août
abl et de quoi cela montre d'abord
l'urgence de la réforme judiciaire
promise par le président de la
république entreprises par le
gouvernement mais on ne voit toujours
rien venir et cela montre aussi
l'urgence de la sauvegarde et peut-être
même de la réhabilitation de la
crédibilité du conseil constitutionnel
tout ce qui ralentit l'une et l'autre
peut être considéré comme inquiétant
merci à la douleur bernard kouchner se
donne trois ans pour mettre en place un
véritable plan d'action pour améliorer
sinon corriger les graves insuffisances
qui existe encore dans le traitement de
la douleur désormais les patients
hospitalisés recevront un carnet douleur
pour mesurer les degrés du mal et puis
lancement d'une campagne d'information
pour venir à bout des dernières
réticences
y compris dans le monde médical lui même
reportage à l'hôpital ambroise paré à
boulogne qui depuis quelques années un
centre pilote antidouleur gens payent
eux jean-pierre pasteur une accidentés
de la route a mené au bloc opératoire et
la deux jambes brisées
dès son arrivée à l'hôpital l'équipe
antidouleur la insensibiliser un
traitement qui sera repris après
l'opération pour ne pas qu'elle est mal
nous lui avons posé un cathéter
péridurale ce qu'elle était à péridurale
lui permet de ne plus avoir mal aux
jambes pendant toute la durée en
attendant d'être transféré au bloc
opératoire pour être opéré c'est à dire
que la douleur est bloquée au niveau des
membres inférieurs
la douleur est bloquée au niveau des
membres inférieurs elle peut bouger les
propos bouger les jambes pour mieux
prendre en compte la souffrance des
patients
le centre leur fait estimé l'intensité
de leur douleur à l'aide d'une réglette
graduée de 1 à 10
l'intensité est noté sur une carte à
côté des autres données température
tension cette mesure devrait est
généralisée dans tous les hôpitaux
le centre utilise de nombreuses
substances anti douleur la principale
étant la morphine la fumière prépare la
dose voulu et la place dans cette
machine qui permet aux patients de se
l'injecter lui même c'est le cas pour
les malades de longue durée comme cet
homme qu'on a dû amputer d'une jambe
avant le tremblement 30 petite douleur
c'étaient c'était insupportable
j'avais l'impression qu'on veut croyez
les gens l'équipe antidouleur comprend
douze personnes dont deux médecins
permanent pour eux le traitement ne se
borne pas administré des drogues
il ya également la kinésithérapie les
traitements anesthésique les traitements
neurochirurgie co les approches
psychologiques qui sont tout à fait
qu'une importante à prendre en compte
aujourd'hui la douleur doit être
considérée comme une vraie maladie qui
exigent comme les autres un traitement
global
il n'y a plus de restauration à bord des
trains sncf un mouvement de grève depuis
11 jours perturbent les usagers après le
blocage cet après midi des voies à la
gare de lyon les syndicats maintiennent
la pression reportage entre paris et
lyon matthieu chedid yoyo la grève du
personnel wagons lits aucun service de
restauration est assurée à bord de notre
tgv pour un message de bienvenue on peut
mieux faire depuis douze jours aucun
croque madame ne sort de ces fours les
bars de la sncf sont fermés motif une
grève des salariés suite au rachat de
leur société par le groupe accor
lyon paris à l'heure du déjeuner petit
mécontentement des passagers c'est pas
pénible mais serait ce un petit côté
désagréable séjour agréable d'aller au
barde moins capé 2
branson
l'autre comme ça ça me gêne pas ça ne
fait pas énormément ça me gêne plus pour
un petit confort personnel de prendre un
café tranquillement
toute la semaine les grévistes ont
multiplié les opérations commando comme
ici dans un hô tel accord les salariés
sont inquiets depuis toujours la sncf
subventionner les entreprises chargées
de la restauration le groupe accor a
obtenu le marché en s'engageant à
redresser seule les comptes c'est noah
qui sont en jeu et nous nous sommes
contre la remise en cause de nos acquis
surtout que
ça va peut-être se traduire sur des
suppressions d'emplois dans quelques en
quelques semaines de vous dans quelques
mois nous comprenons les angoisses
inquiétudes et les inquiétudes du
personnel
on comprend beaucoup moins la méfiance
est beaucoup moins le mouvement de grève
qui était déclenchée avant que l'on ait
remis quelques avantages soient en cause
l'intersyndicale et la direction se
réunissent en ce moment même un accord
pourrait aboutir dans la soirée pour
cette journée internationale des femmes
lionel jeu spa reçoit ce soir dans une
salle de spectacle parisienne les
candidates aux prochaines élections
auparavant lors d'une réception à
matignon en compagnie de personnalités
féminines
lionel jospin a confirmé sa
détermination à inscrire la parité dans
la constitution enfin une journée
marquée par une circulaire signée du
premier ministre pour la féminisation
des noms de métiers de fonction ou de
grade françoise david et marc savinaud
paradoxe on se financent les femmes
socialistes sont à la porte à la porte
du café de la danse trop exigu pour les
accueillir toutes candidates aux
élections régionales elles ont été
convoquées pour célébrer leur journée et
leur combat politique
elle a d'ailleurs valu de la campagne à
la des épices pour offrir aux nantais
rien parce que les épices et presque
simple comme les femmes en politique
c'est presque invisible l'essab agit
contre former la parité hommes-femmes le
gouvernement en a fait une de ses
priorités
les ide a également taclé aujourd'hui un
autre objectif
la féminisation et français
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour la langue
française mais il me paraît opportun de
corriger certaines inégalités
grammaticales qui ne sont que les traces
d'une société disparaît un guide devrait
même être largement diffusée auprès des
usagers pour les familiariser avec le
nouveau vocabulaire
en attendant les femmes socialistes
écoutent est un groupe exclusivement
féminin une pause dans la campagne
demain assuré de nouveau sur le terrain
edouard balladur recevait sur une
péniche sur la seine les candidats des
listes de la région de france s'honore
d'un bep devenu une façon de marquer
cette journée de la femme dans un
instant je recevrai dominique voynet
pour les régionales et les cantonales
des listes dissidentes se réclament de
l'écologie elles ont vu le jour
on vous promet la lune nous vous
promettons la terre
le poids de ces listes d'un autre verts
valérie fournier jan sikken un homme
pressé bruno bonduelle pressé de montrer
sa région ici atouts économiques lui
l'industriel qui s'est lancé dans la
politique et surtout l'économie germinal
du charbon
la tristesse de la misère du xixème
siècle et on entre dans 21e siècle des
technologies hyper moderne
c'est ça le sessad nord pas de calais
aux lions
une place à part sur l'échiquier
politique du nord ancien patron de
droite il se présente au nom de
génération écologie et sa définition de
l'écologie est bien celle d'un patron
d'écologie d'économie le bras sinon ça
vient du grec
eikos high cost vers la maison la maison
donc
économie je gère ma maison au lieu
écologie mme geyler défend contre les
agressions extérieures
et c'est en homme d'affaires qu'il mène
campagne les partis traditionnels de
droite comme de gauche ne l'intéressait
pas pour des formats l'environnement nos
vendeurs c'est l'écologie et l'emploi
c'est pas comme d'autres c'est
l'écologie plus le bolchevisme hugo
suspens je ne sais quelle vieille lune
le sérieux un espace vert ici serait le
bienvenu geneviève vendus et cela il
vaut mieux soutenir au moins le candidat
des écologistes indépendants
un mouvement qui se veut lui à politique
c'est en dehors de la droite et de la
gauche l'écologie est une vraie famille
de pensée c'est une pensée inédites
qu'il remet en cause de fonctionnement
actuel de la société
revenir à la cité revenir la cité
revenir à vos préoccupations des gens
dans leur quotidien c'est tout et au
mans le quotidien c'est comme partout la
pollution les écologistes indépendants
réclament la fermeture de cette usine
d'incinération qui n'est pas aux normes
et dont les rejets noircissent les
potagers 15 salade
mais malgré leurs actions ces
écologistes indépendants auront bien du
mal à se placer devant les verts
dominique voynet bonsoir
revenant sur cette journée des femmes si
j'en crois la circulaire de lionel
jospin et au delà de la querelle des
académiciens je dois vous appeler madame
le ministre madame la ministre madame
l'a évidemment ça me paraît tellement
simple tellement naturel que tout le
monde qui est mis en quelques semaines
comme on dit maintenant madame la
députée est aussi madame la préfète qui
décidément ne va être durablement la
femme du préfet ce n'existe plus ça les
femmes de préfet son avocat des leçons
médecins ils sont professeurs ils sont
mais renvoyé pour certaines d'entre
elles mais elles ne sont certainement
pas prêts fait d'un mot cette circulaire
signée aujourd'hui de la main du premier
ministre c'est un symbole c'est un
cadeau ou c'est un gadget
ça ne peut pas être l'un ou l'autre ça
doit être une marche de plus vers une
parfaite représentation des femmes dans
la vie publique dans la vie économique
dans la vie de la cité
j'espère beaucoup la parité très vite
je crois que nous avons besoin d'avoir
des femmes à tous les niveaux de
responsabilité dans les élections
régionales on a vu que les choses
n'étaient pas tout à fait aussi rose
qu'on l'espérait la plupart des femmes
sur bien des listes soient encore vers
la 5e ou 6e place vous avez cette place
qu'il est gagnable que si vraiment il ya
une reprise hors de l'état veut dire
donc que la parité n'existe pas vraiment
puisqu'elle sans lamelles sont pas
dérangeante elles ne seront pas en tout
cas présidente de région
j'ai compté qu'il y avait quinze femmes
têtes de liste sur 99 département vous
avez aussi qu'il ya une seule femme qui
est présidente de région c'est marketing
global dans le nord pas de calais ça me
semblerait tout à fait dommage qu'il
reste seul à la tête d'une région
pourquoi pas une deuxième femme et moi
que ce n'est pas si elle va rester à la
tête de cette région parce
qu'apparemment elle a un concurrent
socialiste qui nichaient delbarre vous
comptez vous toujours faire la bataille
vient de michel delbarre bien sûr je ne
vois aucun argument valable pour que
marie christine blandin ne continue pas
l'excellent travail qu'il a fait et en
ce jour des femmes
je pense que je viens de trouver un
argument supplémentaire dites moi ce ne
doit pas toujours être facile de jouer
entre la solidarité du gouvernement et
puis finalement vos propres aspirations
par exemple le mouvement des chômeurs
ils vous disaient à besançon vendredi
dominique ne nous lâche pas je n'ai pas
l'intention de les lâcher
lionel jospin nous a donné comme mission
est comme priorités au gouvernement la
lutte contre le chômage et l'exclusion
j'ai bien l'intention de l'écouter ce
premier ministre avec lequel je
travaille tous les jours ils auraient
raison descendent dans la rue les
chômeurs de demander les fruits de la
croissance tout de suite je pense qu'ils
ont raison de maintenir la pression pour
que personne ne les oublie je pense
aussi que leur aspiration à une
revalorisation des minima sociaux est
légitime
je crois effectivement que la croissance
une fois conçu l'idée
tous les bénéfices de cette croissance
doivent être investis d'une part pour
désigner notre pays qui souffre du poids
de sa dette mais aussi pour redistribuer
une partie des richesses à ceux qui
souffrent cruellement dans leur vie
quotidienne
jean pierre chevènement 10 avant-hier la
campagne se traîne à qui la faute vous
avez pas su intéresser concernés les
gens d'ailleurs c'est un peu ce que
disent les sondages
la campagne se traîne je crois que c'est
lié en partie au fait qu'il ya deux
élections même jour deux élections pour
des assemblées qui sont mal connus nous
avons vraiment intérêt à faire campagne
sur les contenus et donner des arguments
positifs à nos électeurs
je j'ai envie de leur dire deux choses
la première c'est qu'il est vraiment
important de donner à ce gouvernement
les moyens d'aller plus loin
vite plus fort avec eux le deuxième
argument que j'aurais leur donner c'est
que décidément ces assemblées le conseil
régional le conseil général depuis la
décentralisation ont acquis énormément
de pouvoir
il est fondamental pour la rénovation
des lycées pour des structures de
formation pour la vie des quartiers pour
l'emploi pour les transports collectifs
d'avoir des majorités associant la
gauche et les verts lors une question
essentielle que l'on censure tout à fait
quelques jours des élections le vote
front national semble embarrasser la
plupart des états majors politiques
philippe seguin disait d'ailleurs
qu'elle a semblé y aurait au moins 70
députés socialistes qui devrait
démissionner parce que il aurait été
soutenue moi je suis absolument
scandalisé par la façon dont ce thème
qui est un thème très sérieux très grave
est instrumentalisée par les parties
rien ne justifie qu'on fasse du front
national des idées du front national des
voix du front national à les thèmes
essentiels de la campagne
je crois que les partis politiques et
singulièrement les partis de la majorité
plurielle doivent conquérir leurs
électeurs en positif sur leurs
programmes sur leur projet et pas en
accusant forcément l'autre camp des
pires avanies
moi je fais le pari que la vitalité de
la démocratie est à ce prix faucon
convaincre nos électeurs pas qu'on leur
montre les autres du doigt en agitant
des chiffons rouges qui ne trompe plus
personne parlement il ya encore du
travail à faire à travers ces élections
à ce que les verts compte toucher les
dividendes de leur participation au
gouvernement
les verts ont choisi de s'engager sur
les listes de la majorité plurielle nous
aurons un certain nombre d'élus en
situation de prendre des responsabilités
dans les régions nous aurons aussi avec
nos 700 à 800 candidats aux élections
cantonales des élus et les conseils
généraux
c'était la preuve que la stratégie des
verts d'être actifs créatifs et moteur
du changement au sein de la majorité
plurielle était le bon choix
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions à
mme ou encore de politiques avec cette
mise en garde du président du rpr
philippe séguin met en garde jean
françois mancel le l'ancien secrétaire
général du mouvement monsieur mancelle
avait déclaré qu'il ne refuserait pas
les voix du front national nous en
parlions philippe séguin le menace de
sanctions à paris plusieurs milliers de
personnes ne soutiennent la cause de
tibétaine pour cette troisième
manifestation européenne
après bruxelles et genève une
cinquantaine d'associations avait appelé
les manifestants venus de plusieurs pays
drapeau tibétain ballan et portrait du
dalaï lama avec ses slogans liberté au
tibet danielle mitterrand se trouvaient
dans le cortège
un immense drapeau tibétain bleu rouge
jaune vert et blanc mesurant 130 mètres
sur 90 a été déployé sur une partie du
trocadéro
jacques chirac lance un appel à une
réaction urgente et déterminée de la
communauté internationale au kosovo
la crainte d'une nouvelle guerre civile
au coeur des discussions avec
aujourd'hui à paris madeleine albright
secrétaire d'état américain sur place
des milliers de femmes ont manifesté à
pristina la capitale pour dénoncer la
répression serbe les autorités jouent
l'apaisement
les sardines et plusieurs milliers
d'albanais ce matin devant la
représentation américaine de christina
une page blanche à la main elles
manifestent non pour leur condition de
femme mais pour celle des leurs de leur
fils pères ou maris victimes de la
répression des forces serbes au kosovo
et pendant ce temps à paris
une autre femme madeleine albright le
secrétaire d'état américain venu évoquer
avec hubert védrine la situation au
kosovo
moi mais je crois que c'est très
important de faire savoir ce qu'il fait
acceptable officiellement sur le terrain
les opérations de police sont terminées
comme en témoignent ces images de prise
d'armes diffusé par la télévision de
belgrade et celle de cette visite
organisée pour des représentants de la
croix rouge et des diplomates
après case au centre de la province un
déplacement qui n'a pas convaincu les
milieux diplomatiques sans solution
politique véritable le feu plus
reprendre à tout moment dans cette
région des balkans
il est clair et c'est notre analyse
commune en tout cas que la situation est
grave qu'elle appelle des mesures
urgentes et que nous aurons à nous
déterminer avec beaucoup de fermeté et
de clarté pour enrayer immédiatement
l'engrenage que l'on voit commencé à se
développer dès demain les
six pays du groupe de contact france
etats unis russie grande bretagne italie
allemagne se réuniront ici à londres
pour chercher ensemble et dans l'urgence
une solution politique et la crise mais
la russie s'oppose par avance à toute
sanction contre belgrade et le président
milosevic a rejeté ce matin toute action
internationale en faveur de la paix un
peu partout dans le monde les femmes
sont descendus aujourd'hui dans la rue
alger par exemple plusieurs dizaines
d'entre elles ont eu le courage de
manifester contre le code de la famille
bernard lebrun vraiment un problème
les plus audacieuses les plus
courageuses de la cause des femmes
travers le monde les femmes d'alger car
il faut beaucoup d'abnégation et de
détermination aujourd'hui en algérie
pour osé descendre dans la rue
dénoncer le code de la famille et
l'excision des petites filles elles
n'étaient pas nombreuses mais en ce 8
mars
elle tenait à prendre la parole ces
moments de lutte
ces moments aussi résistant contre la
barbarie années grises qui touche les
pannes qu'il est bien le terme utile
mais aussi pour dire non au recul qui
concerne les lois ces dernières 48
heures trente deux personnes ont été
tuées lors d'attentats dont quatre
femmes le régime turc lui a battu tous
les records
cette manifestation pacifiste d'environ
2000 personnes a été déclaré illégal
alors que ces femmes refusaient de se
disperser les forces de l'ordre des
hommes bien sûr aux charges et les
manifestantes faisant des dizaines de
blessés
beaucoup moins nombreuses et sous la
pluie les femmes allemandes comme
partout en occident ont manifesté leur
soutien aux femmes afghanes y algérienne
thème retenu par tous pour cette journée
internationale de la femme journée
internationale donc des femmes avec la
souffrance des femmes afghanes un
rassemblement de soutien cet après midi
à paris place de la république à
l'initiative de danielle mitterrand
présidente de france libertés sous le
régime des taliban les femmes afghanes
le peuvent ni travailler ni étudié ni
circuler seul le ministre de la santé
les a exclus des centres de soins
l'enquète dans ce journal à kaboul et
dans les camps de réfugiés au pakistan
jérôme bunny et franck vaillant vue
d'une chambre de l'hôtel
intercontinental dont le poste de télé a
été retiré kaboul haut lieu de la
révolution islamique à l'afghane ici la
reproduction de l'image est formellement
interdite
les talibans étudiants en religion
veille au grain caché derrière les
vitres de leurs pick up japonais à la
radio deschamps talibans mais pas de
musique considérée comme fantaisie
obscène tels des fantômes rasant les
murs les femmes source de tentations un
pur ne peuvent sortir dans la rue peu
couvertes de la tête aux pieds par le
tchadri le voile traditionnelle à banque
qu'on avait un peu oublié à kaboul ces
dernières décennies
elles vivent dans un climat entretenu de
peur et de culpabilité
et c'est seulement dans les camps de
réfugiés au pakistan
quelles peuvent témoigner un jour je me
rendais un séminaire je portais le voile
le tchadri même je marchais dans la rue
et soudain à la briviste quelqu'un m'a
donné un coup de fouet sur la tête
c'est alors que j'ai décidé de quitter
kaboul dans cette clinique
nouria a pu continuer son travail
d'infirmière alors qu'en afghanistan les
femmes n'ont plus le droit d'exercer une
profession
ici le tchador et comme un signe de
libération
découvrant les visages de l'incertitude
et de la douleur
je sais qu est ce que le dieu et dis et
je fais quelques honnête je n'étais pas
là talibans et qu'est-ce qu'il vous dit
juste mon dieu est ce seulement cachées
de l'écheveau pas le visage l'ambiance
studieuse de cette école est aussi le
privilège de l'exil en afghanistan
maintenant
l'enseignement est interdit aux filles
après l'âge de 9 ans l'ordre talibans a
plus d'impact sur ceux qui n'ont jamais
accédé à l'éducation comme ces familles
pauvres qui viennent de fuir les combats
du nord de kaboul
la place d'une femme et à la maison dans
sa tombe pas dans la rue pour qu'ils
payent infirmières quand c'est elle que
sa place était à l'hôpital dont elle a
été renvoyée du jour au lendemain
martin dans l'homme et la femme
le médecin et l'infirmière n'ont pas le
droit d'être un ensemble de discuter une
description en octobre dernier le
ministre de la santé des talibans
décrète que les femmes n'ont plus le
droit d'être soigné dans les mêmes
hôpitaux que les hommes
maintenant les médecins doivent faire
une ségrégation entre leurs patients les
femmes malades viennent ici pour se
faire soigner mais compte tenu des
nouveaux règlements nous ne pouvons pas
laisser les médecins de ce service ont
perdu la moitié de leur collaboratrice
licencié parce qu'elle est et femmes
nous pensions qu'avec le temps les
règles s'assouplirait mais bien au
contraire elles sont de plus en plus dur
occasion pour la population
pour les quelques milliers de femmes
afghanes qui avait réussi à accéder à
une certaine modernité la prise du
pouvoir par les talibans a entraîné un
gigantesque retour en arrière qui a
effacé ici à kaboul trente ans de
progrès de la condition féminine en
italie après la condamnation hier à la
prison à vie d'eric kripke et carlos
condamnation plus lourde que celle
qu'ils avaient obtenu en première
instance tout les anciens d'officiers
nazis ont décidé de saisir la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme les
deux hommes condamnés une première fois
15 ans de prison avaient reconnu leur
participation au massacre de 335 civils
ou sousse ardéatines le début de la
saison en formule 1 avec la victoire de
mclaren mercedes sur le circuit de
melbourne
c'est le finlandais mika hakkinen qui a
remporté le grand prix d'australie
laurent frédéric bollée
les larmes sincères de mika hakkinen le
vainqueur la joie des mécaniciens le
sourire du patron ron dennis le triomphe
de mclaren mercedes est totale l'équipe
obtient son 108e succès en grand prix
avec l'art et la manière
les deux pilotes hakkinen et coulthard
tu avait en effet passé un pacte celui
qui virait en tête au premier virage
devait gagner la course
un scénario respectée au delà des
espérances avec à la clé une
démonstration technologique et sportive
car tandis que schumacher sur la ferrari
abandonne dès le 6e tour moteur explosé
et en jette son volant de rage tandis
que villeneuve concède un tour une route
que 5e
les mclaren font donc un festival
pourtant à keenan a failli tout perdre
en route pour son deuxième
ravitaillement il ne s'arrête en fait
pas du tout à son stand
l'écurie est le pilote ne se sont pas
compris l'erreur coûte cher à keenan
perd alors sa première place mais chez
mclaren dix ans pile après l'époque
glorieuse mais empoisonnée pro sénat on
a désormais le sens de la parole donnée
coulthard respecte nos pattes ailées
spatiale c'est un geste très sonné vers
un geste d'excellence que je n'oublierai
pas
c'est le reflet d'une conception de la
course une conception qui détonne dans
le monde de la f1 moderne mais chez
mclaren l'union fait la force et c'est
semble-t-il le retour irrésistible des
flèches d'argent sur les circuits
première étape du paris-nice un
contre-la-montre de 10 km entre assurés
nés paris c'est le belge frank
vandenbroucke qui l'a remporté quant au
français laurent jalabert favoris de
l'épreuve
il termine à la deuxième place
et puis le tirage au sort des quarts de
finale de la coupe de france de football
a élu aujourd'hui bourg peronnas le
petit poucet ira donc jouer contre lyon
sont voisins géographiques
à noter le choc qui opposera le psg à
monaco
les autres matches caen contre lens et
guingamp face à mulhouse matchs qui
auront lieu le 21 mars prochain
voilà le tableau les défilés
prêt-à-porter automne-hiver commence
demain à paris pour une dizaine de jours
nous sommes allés à la rencontre d'un
créateur belge dries van noten l'un des
plus talentueux de sa génération
pour suivre les tout derniers
préparatifs avant les défilés reportages
ce film est l clémence galles un tour de
piste une minute pour convaincre cet
après midi des 150 visages qui se sont
succédé sous le regard de dries van
noten une poigne ont été retenues pour
donner corps dans deux jours à une
collection qui ne transportera de
hongrie en russie des mannequins ni trop
lisse ni trop douce pour ne pas sombrer
dans le folklore quelque chose de
spécial comme ça une fac il marche et
après quand on hésite on prend un pas la
rue parce que l heure on peut voir que
les films x sont très trop peu une
allure de petit garçon sauvage le
cheveux en pétard comme au temps des
gitans la touche finale pour parfaire
l'histoire c'est la coiffure que l'on
pesticides avec une star du métier
yannick disent avoir été bâti dans les
très léger très léger
deux heures de retard la collection
vienne arrivée par camion de milan où
elle a été présentée avant même de
défiler au premier acheteur prototype
taille 38 mille deux cents pièces sont
déshabillés à la hâte
tu vois tous les éléments mais tu sais
seulement quand ton imagination
parce que donc c'est la fin de sa
lumière sa musique mais quelle coiffure
vêtements
l'un donc je suis tu vois c'est que
c'est seulement à la fin qu'on voit ce
que ça donne en étoffes précieuses
lettres gros des mousselines pas été
gonflées d'or imprimés griffé par le
temps sont alignés par ordre de passage
tout ici n'est que contraste féminin
masculin rustique et délicat à quelques
encablures de la scène sous un chapiteau
le décor du défilé se montrent mardi
quand les lumières se rallument rond il
faudra séduire en très exactement 17
minutes et 15 secondes cinéma avec la
sortie et mercredi d'une comédie dans
laquelle on retrouve antoine de caunes
et elsa zylberstein
l'homme est une femme comme les autres
un titre prometteur avec pour point de
départ l'histoire d'un jeune
clarinettiste juif et homosexuel qui
rencontre la naïve rosalie stéphane
haumant à frédéric basket
presque tout papa samia été exterminés
puis le seul garçon qui nous restent ne
peut pas laisser disparaître votre nom
ou cassés
simon préfère les garçons se moque de la
religion et joue de la clarinette
mais pour pouvoir hériter simon va
devoir se marier aux roses alliel aime
la musique elle est juive bière naïve la
proie idéale
l'homme est une femme comme les autres
histoire d'une imposture au jeu de
l'amour et du désir de la sexualité tu
le sais tu comment choqué si ça t'amuse
jeunes même ceux restés tout les
positions je les connais par coeur je
veux dire que tu connais par coeur
en théorie le cette histoire vraiment
particulier on va dire on a on débouche
sur des choses qui me semblent moi très
très universel quoi et qui peuvent dire
quelque chose à des gens qui ne sont ni
homosexuel ni juif ni des jeunes
chanteuses venons ligue letra religieux
destinés à rester vierge jusqu'à leur
mariage
très régulier je mange casher quand
c'est chabal chaline les bogies et
j'arrête de travailler
c'est cet acte reste provient non tous
admirable moi je me suis jamais nice et
une gourde moi je me suis dit elle croit
en ce qu'elle veut elle a foi en son
amour de l'art à la fois elle rencontre
le midel elle est folle de joie
laisser-aller illuminé un côté ces deux
là n'ont rien en commun mais ils sont
faits l'un pour l'autre
par la grâce d'allah zylberstein simon
imposteurs se fait piéger
depuis [ __ ] douce les comédie gay sont
à la mode celle-ci mari avait une
drôlerie homosexualité et religion le
film relève peut-être là une ambiguïté
mais il le fait sans choquer je crois
est ce que ça me ça me plairait pas de
choquer genre ça serait trop facile pour
y restaurer à la porte du chiffre moi
j'ai envie qu'ils rentrent antoine de
caunes accouche de son premier vrai rôle
de cinéma le film ne pêche que par sa
fin un peu conventionnel broadway à
paris avec sur scène la comédie musicale
fait célèbre comédie musicale c'est une
équipe entièrement américaine qui a
envahi la scène des folies bergères
nicolas winckler et céline rem linge et
aux folies bergères pour la journée de
la femme
nous avons trouvé un homme qui aime
autant les femmes que frame il a vu le
spectacle trois fois c'est beaucoup a
dit une fois oui voir faire une trois
fois pourquoi abbas est là où ça
ça veut dire un cours de danse à
laguardia high school une école mythique
aux états unis quatre années durant ils
vont tout donner en espérant la gloire
vous avez aimé le film vous avez aimé la
série alors peut-être aimerait vous ce
show très énergique et très américain
une histoire à la morale quelque peu
manichéenne
dieu nous a choisis pour être les
meilleurs et c'est en travaillant avec
acharnement et en étant sage avec les
filles qu'on va y arriver
mince on n'est pas là pour rigoler
beaucoup des jeunes artistes jouent
finalement sur scène leur propre
histoire comme l'acteur principal
né dans les quartiers pauvres des
indianapolis le sujet c'est comment on
poursuit ses rêves comment poursuit les
tentatives avec des difficultés qu'on
rencontre un grand loup ça je crois que
devenir une superstar a beaucoup à voir
avec la chance nombreux d'entre elles ne
sont guère mieux que beaucoup d amis qui
m'entourent
de l'énergie un spectacle plus que
parfaitement rodé l'histoire se finit
bien et mal bien parce que les bons
élèves obtiennent leur diplôme mal parce
que carmen la plus talentueuse fini avec
des trous dans ses bas et des trous dans
les veines à naufrage sur le chemin
difficile de la célébrité et comme tout
le monde le sait dans le monde du
showbiz il faut se méfier de la poudre
en général et de la poudre aux yeux en
particulier sis termine cette édition je
vous rappelle les principaux titres
affluence record pour le salon de
l'agriculture qui vient de fermer ses
portes
six cent mille visiteurs en une semaine
journée internationale des femmes avec
notamment la souffrance des femmes
naviguent années algériennes et puis
aussi mobilisation à berlin à parisienne
et le jospin annonce sa volonté
d'inscrire la parité dans la
constitution
dans un instant la météo isabelle
martinez 7h50 demain matin dans les
quatre vérités
françoise laborde recevra marie george
buffet ministre de la jeunesse et des
sports 13 heures à l'occasion des
régionales patrick chêne sera en direct
de rennes demain soir vous retrouverez
daniel bilalian je vous remercie de
votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
ce soir